The apply function and its
variants are useful for
applying a function across
an R object.
We'll consider two variants
of the special class of
functions--
apply and tapply--
and we'll also look at
the by function.
I'm going to start by loading
in a new data set--
website revenue for the month
of March for 10 businesses.
I've used the argument header
equals false because there are
no call names stored in this
comma separated values file.
The data in this data matrix
have been stored in a slightly
unorthodox way--
each business is represented
as a column and each row
represents a day, in order, of
March 1 through March 31.
So for example, on March 3, the
10th business made $23.98.
It might be helpful for me to
take a quick look at how the
businesses are doing by taking a
look at their total revenue.
I could take the sum for each
column using a for loop and
store that result in a vector,
but this would actually be
inefficient.
Instead, I should use the apply
function, which will be
more compact and also run faster
with larger data sets.
The apply function is useful for
applying a function across
either the rows or columns
of a data matrix.
That is, I might want to apply
a function across each row
separately or across each
column separately.
The first argument is the
data matrix itself.
The second argument is the
dimension number over which to
apply the function.
Rows are represented by number
1 and columns by number 2.
Think of the second argument
as specifying the dimension
that you actually
want to retain.
The last argument is the
function to be applied.
In a similar way, we can also
compute the total revenue for
all the companies on each day
of the month by applying the
sum function over each
of the rows.
Notice that there are some
missing observations.
If we look into the data more
carefully, we would find that
there are two missing values,
each in the third column.
If we know that it's OK to omit
these data, we can tell
the sum function to ignore the
missing observations using NA
remove equals true.
The apply function passes
this argument
onto the sum function.
Generally, any extra arguments
to apply will be passed to the
function you specify in
the third argument.
In this particular use case,
we probably should want to
investigate the missing
observations, rather than
simply ignore them.
Also, just a technical note, for
this application of apply,
I could've used either the call
sums or row sums functions.
All right, onwards to the
second function--
tapply.
To help explain this new
function, I'm going to load in
a second data set that
summarizes eBay auctions for
the Mario Kart video
game for the Wii.
This is a tab-delimited text
file of the data, so I'm going
to read it in using
the read.delim.
To keep things simple, let's
focus on three variables--
wheels, conditions,
and total price.
The tapply function is similar
to the apply function in that
it helps aggregate
data efficiently.
For instance, we could examine
the sum of all of the total
prices of auctions that were
new and used separately by
providing the vector for the
total price as the first
argument, the vector for the
conditions as the second, and
then the sum function
as the third.
Just like in apply, the third
argument for the tapply
function is another function to
be applied across the data.
However, in this case, the
function is applied to each
group, where the groups are
specified by the second
argument, which in this case, is
the condition of the game.
I'm going to modify this command
a little bit since it
makes more sense to look at the
average price of the game.
As you might have anticipated,
the games that are new tend to
sell for more than the
games that are used.
Here, the difference
is about $10.
There's a second important
variable in this application
that relates to the price--
the number of steering
wheels that come with
the game in the auction.
These steering wheels are a
game accessory the make
playing Mario Kart
a bit more fun.
Let's look at the average price
of the auctions with
different numbers of
wheels included.
As you might expect, we again
see a steady increase in price
associated with having
more wheels
included in the auction--
about $6 to $10 per wheel.
Now, there's something
interesting
to think about here.
If I consider the influence of
both price and the number of
wheels simultaneously, what will
this do to the estimated
cost of a new game versus a used
game, and also the cost
of an extra wheel?
A table to look at the average
price across each of the
combinations of condition and
wheels can be made using the
tapply function.
To do this, I'm going to provide
the data frame with
just the condition and
the wheels columns
as the second argument.
Some of these numbers look
a little bit surprising.
For instance, going from no
wheels to one wheel doesn't
seem to influence the price
when the game is new.
If we dig in a little more
here, using the length
function in place of the mean
function, I can see that one
of the groups had very few
observations, and so this
average is probably less
reliable, and this might
explain the difference.
If I was going to continue this
analysis, I'd probably
look into this some more.
One last function before
we wrap up.
The by function is a variant of
the tapply function, but,
by default, it returns a
vector of the results.
Note that when it is printed,
it won't really look like a
vector, though you could access
the elements just as if
it was a vector.
In the next video, we'll take
a look at three functions--
with, within, and aggregate.